hi sarah welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi hey what's up so i have a question
i graduated undergrad my undergrad
degree
debt-free and i'm currently working on a
law degree paying as i go and working
full-time so that i can graduate
debt-free
great but i'm also contributing to my
401k and i'm
doing the full 15 percent of my paycheck
and my company has a good match i've
seen some articles online
that seem to make it appear that the new
administration
doesn't look favorably on 401ks and
wants to
possibly you know diminish them so i'm
wondering if i should do anything with
the 401k that i have now
no i have not seen that
trend by anything credible
but i have no idea what the biden
administration is going to do
and we do not have the benefit of checks
and balances
in that they can pass anything through a
democrat senate democratic congress so i
don't know what they'll pass
um i i would think
it would be very difficult and political
suicide to screw with the
largest wealth building tool in america
but who knows
these are strange times so uh it doesn't
mean though that i wouldn't put
money into it in anticipation of some
bizarre political event
and by the way that would be the
definition of a bizarre political event
for him to do that in years past would
have been political suicide today i
don't even know what that means but um
uh so i i
i used to say things like oh no way they
would never do that but i have no idea
in this world right now what they're
going to do
but i don't i i will continue to put
money in my 401 k
until i have different information than
i have today
which i don't have any information
that's credible that makes me think it's
one of the you know biden
administration's
top priorities to do away with america's
primary wealth building tool
yeah i'm not seeing anything on that uh
that would not be an overnight uh result
that would there would be some serious
serious conversation about that
and an uproar to say the least uh and
and so i don't think you need to be
fearful at all i agree with dave on that
but yeah i mean you know
get beyond that 401k you know here you
are you're off and running and you're
you're you're uh cash flowing uh your
education you're going to do very very
well
and so begin to look at you know the
diversified plan that we teach here at
ramsey solutions you know
retire inspired be a great book for you
at this stage to begin to see
what's the future look like and what are
all the ways that i could
uh prepare for the future but no don't
don't be in a state of fear right now
and that's part of the problem dave is i
understand there's uncertainty for
75 million americans let's just be
really honest you have a very divided
country and an election that obviously
all kinds of stuff going around it and
and i can tell you this i'm not a spring
chicken but i'm not an old man either
but i've been around
enough to watch a lot of elections and a
lot of change in power
and one thing that i just want to tell
our audience
your side is not as pure as you think
they are
and the other side's not as evil as you
think they are either so relax
you don't need to look to washington dc
for your future
you don't and stay the course keep doing
smart things and don't freak out fear is
never a great place to operate from yeah
i can promise you this if they do do
away with the 401k we'll be here to help
you
figure out what to do that is true and
we will be ready we'll show you what to
do that is true and uh there's something
to do
there's always something to do there's
always a way to do things but i really
truly uh i would be shocked and amazed
but i will caveat that with saying i
have been shocked
and amazed that's right years of what
these
characters will pull off on both sides
of the aisle